we're on problem 80
problem 80. if a b and c are integers
is a minus b plus c greater okay so they
want to know is
a
minus b
plus c
greater than
a
plus
b
minus c
fair enough and if you think about it
there's an a on both sides of this
equation so they're really wanting to
know is
minus b
plus c
greater than
b
minus c
or another way they're just trying to
say right i just took a from both sides
of this inequality so it doesn't change
anything or not really what they're
asking if you just rearrange this is is
c minus b
greater than b
minus
c
which is another way of saying well is
one of them greater than the other one
right if c is greater than b this is
going to be greater than this one if b
is greater than c this is going to be
greater than this one so let's look at
our statements now statement number one
b is negative
well that by itself doesn't help us much
because
b could be negative but c could be even
more negative so c could still be
smaller than b right if b could be minus
five c could be minus six or c could be
plus six so it really tells us nothing
about c relative to b
statement two says
c is positive
so this statement by itself once again
it tells us nothing about the value of b
relative to c if c is positive maybe b
is positive as well maybe b is more
positive or maybe b is negative who
knows but this by itself doesn't help us
but if we use both of these together if
c is positive and b is negative then we
know
if this is positive this is negative we
know this is going to be positive
and we know that this is going to be
negative
right essentially we know that c is
larger than b so this will be positive
this will be negative and we can answer
our question if c is larger than b
if c is larger than b
this is true
the left-hand side is greater than the
right-hand side or this
holds good so we need both of the
statements together both statements
together are sufficient to answer this
question
so which colors
if a certain animated cartoon consists
of a total of
frames
frames on film how many minutes will it
take to run the cartoon so they want to
know how many minutes
so essentially if we knew how fast the
frames have to go through if it's you
know x frames per second if we knew that
number we'd be able to figure out how
long the
the cartoon runs
so statement one is the cartoon runs
without interruption at a at a rate of
24 frames per second well that's exactly
what i just asked for
24 frames
per second so using just that
information how many seconds does it run
well it runs 17 280 frames divided by 24
frames per second this will give you
seconds
and then if you divide this number by 60
you'll get minutes
times 60 or divided by 60 is equal to
minutes
divide seconds by 60 you get minutes so
this is the answer so one alone was
enough to answer the question
what does statement two give us i'll
write it here
statement two it takes six times as long
to run the cartoon as it takes to rewind
the film and it takes a total of 14
minutes to do
both six times
as long to run the cartoon as it takes
to rewind so
six times
the minutes let's say to run
let me i have to let's say six times to
play
i want different letters
six times
so to play the cartoon takes six times
as long as to rewind the cartoon
and they say it takes a total of 14
minutes to do both so they say play
plus
rewind
is equal to 14.
and what we want to know is how long
does it take to play the movie and we
don't even have to use that information
alone but this 17280 but just looking at
this we have two linear equations and
two unknowns so we can just solve for p
p is the play time of this movie and if
you wanted to figure it out not that you
would have to because we would be done
at this point we would say oh one and
two are each independently sufficient to
answer this question but just to show
you that we could figure it out
say r is equal to 14 minus p then you
substitute that into that
right this is that substitute in you get
p is equal to 6 times r so 6 times 14 is
60 plus 24 84 minus 6p
you get 7p is equal to 84. p is equal to
12 minutes and we'd be done but actually
we didn't have to do all that's a waste
of time
just want to prove it to you
at2 a box contains only red chips white
chips and blue chips if a chip is
randomly selected from the box what is
the probability the chip will either be
white
white or blue so essentially to answer
this we just have to know what
proportion of the chips in the bag are
white or blue
all right so statement says one says the
probability that the chip will be blue
is one-fifth
so probability of blue is equal to
one-fifth that also tells us that
one-fifth of the chips in the bag are
blue but we don't know what what
what proportion are white so we still
can't answer that top question
statement two tells us
the probability that the chip will be
red is one-third
the probability of red is equal to
one-third
so once again just this alone we don't
know what the well actually just this
alone is fine right because uh
i correct myself the chips are only
the the probability of getting white or
blue right that's probability of white
we could write do set notation white or
blue
that is just equal to what it's one
minus the probability that we get a red
right think about that i'm either going
to either this is going to be true i'm
going to pick a white or a blue or i'm
going to pick a red because there's only
red white and blue in the bag so the
probability
of white or
blue
is equal to 1 minus the probability of
red
which is equal to 1 minus 1 3 which is
equal to two-thirds so statement two
alone is sufficient and then if we have
statement number two statement one alone
is not sufficient
eighty-three
see this is this is tricky because i
think you know at least when i first
read it i was like oh i could use this
and this to figure out the probability
of getting a white so i need both
statements but we don't even need to
know the probability of y we just need
to know the probability of a white or
blue which is just 1 minus the
probability of red so statement 2 alone
gets us there
let me do the next problem
if the successive tick marks shown on
the number line are equally spaced and
if x and y are the numbers designated
designating the endpoints of the
interval as shown what is the value
of
y
okay so let me see if i can
draw what they have drawn
so they have a number line i probably
have to draw the exact same number of
ticks as they did
so they have
zero and then let's see this
one tick
two ticks
and then they have a third tick
and they say this is x
and then they have three more
one two
three
and then they have y
and then they have one more it just
keeps going on and on
and they ask us okay if this
if there the ticks are equally spaced
and if x and y are the numbers
designated at the endpoints of intervals
as shown what is the value of
y
so they're equally spaced but they're
not telling us that these are integers
we don't know that you know this is one
this is two this is 3. we don't know
that but what we do know is
we do know that
y
is
how much further than x
so
see x is
x is
one two three spaces so we could say x
is equal to three times
let's say s
right where s is the length of each
interval or each tick and y is one two
3 4
5 6 7. so y is equal to
7 s and so we could use this to come up
with a relation with x and y this is
before they've done anything this is
just looking at the the diagram so if we
want to we could say that
s is equal to y over 7
or if we substitute this back here we
could say that
x is equal to sorry x is equal to 3 over
7y and actually you didn't have to even
do this s stuff you could have just said
oh well x is 3 7 as far as y is from 0
because these are equally spaced so just
the problem set up just looking at it
gives us that information
but we want to know what the value of y
is and that by itself isn't enough what
does statement 1 tell us
x is equal to one-half
x is equal to one-half well that's
enough to figure out why if x is equal
to one-half you just substitute there
one-half is equal to sevenths
y multiply both sides by seven thirds
you get y is equal to what seven over
six and you're done you don't have to
solve that you just know that i have
this i have that i can solve it so one
alone is sufficient
statement two
tells us y minus x
is equal to two thirds
so once again we have
one two equations two linear equations
with two unknowns we can just substitute
and solve them and just to prove it to
you x is equal to 3 7 y i could
substitute that right there so i have y
minus 3 7
y is equal to two thirds
so 7 7 minus 3 7.
so
that's just to go here
7 7 y so it's 4
y is equal to two thirds
y is equal to two thirds times seven
over four
which is
that's one this is two which is seven
over six once again
seven
over six
see you in the next video so once again
each of these are independently
sufficient to answer the question
see you soon